[Música]
se trata de una reserva africana cerca a
parís
guarín
un parque zoológico de 150 hectáreas que
alberga a unos 1500 animales en
semilibertad
con medio millón de visitantes al año es
el tercer parque de entretenimiento más
visitado en isla de francia
el safari es la actividad emblemática
del parque ocho kilómetros de recorrido
en vehículo o camión para descubrir a
los animales
la suerte que tenemos con el camión de
safari es poder recorrer lugares a los
que los vehículos no pueden acceder y
ello permite ver de cerca los animales
que a veces se apartan de las rutas y
así la gente no los puede ver bien
sí
nosotros
en el futuro
no sé cómo posible
se recorre toda la reserva durante una
hora y media lo cual permite
maravillarse frente a las 180 especies
de animales presentes en el parque
[Música]
esta formula constituya la reputación de
tu aridez en su apertura en
[Música]
un proyecto loco imaginado por el hall
de la paz
cincuenta y tres años más tarde recuerda
con emoción que al principio era el
único en creer en su sueño
todo el mundo decía que no funcionaría y
que se matarían entre ellos debo decir
que cuando abrimos doscientas jaulas y
los animales salieron nos preguntamos
es que va a ocurrir
los animales corrieron se detuvieron el
espacio era grande no conocían cómo
empezaron a pasear y lo divertido fue
cuando un día se constituyeron todas las
manadas el jefe el chivo expiatorio tal
como lo había previsto
desde entonces stuart y se volvió una
institución que ha sabido renovarse
constantemente
construido hace 10 años estos túneles
impresionantes les permiten a los
visitantes admirar a las grandes fieras
desde lo muy cerca
vamos
[Aplausos]
mi papá
en unión
cuentas
lejos del público un equipo de choque se
prepara para una operación delicada
trastear a la serpiente más imponente
del mundo una anaconda
voy a la voy a ir al fondo wickens
todo uno detrás de los otros
y de paco tous no está contenta será un
poco complicado pero lo haremos es un
animal peligroso que puede morder o
enroscarse para asfixiar a sus presas
ahí va vamos vamos
lo logramos los unimos a álex hay 7
bomberos de la brigada animal de
billings
vamos y regresemos
soy yo ataviado muchacho saliendo
cativo la responsable de los reptiles
aprovecha para hacerle un examen de
sangre no puede demorarse capi
la medimos si en general es imposible
medirla la oportunidad es perfecta
no puedo hacer nada por ahora ahora si
el reptil mide cuatro metros cincuenta
centímetros y pesa 87 kilos
ubíquense en el costado externo
unos cuantos metros más lejos la hembra
anaconda descubre su nuevo hogar
vámonos
nadie en frente
ahora
[Música]
la molestamos la estimulamos la
serpiente parece apreciar
su cuidadora también
es una gran alegría verla en un estanque
más grande y un descanso porque hubo
mucha preparación
el bienestar de los animales es una
prioridad en tu are y conviven en
grandes espacios un modo de vida más
afín a su entorno natural que les
permite conservar sus instintos salvajes
i